do you think January 6th was a big deal
I do
how big of a deal compared to what
uh Civil War
I think it was less of a big deal than
the Civil War okay no I mean so you well
it's a very interesting thing though
right because we have not only the the
event that's that's clever actually it's
not only the event but it's what led up
to it and what has happened since and
did it change what is considered on the
table
that citizens can should or might do if
they disagree with the results of an
election so I think that there are
further reaching consequences than just
was the six hour period on January 6th a
bigger smaller deal than the Civil War
and there's so much wrapped up into it